this video is brought to you by morning
brew
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
in the early 1980s a new technology
called the video game was changing the
face of american business
the biggest name in the industry was
atari in only three years
their annual revenue had gone from 75
million dollars to 2
billion this made atari the fastest
growing company in the history of the
united states
but today atari is nothing more than a
shell
of its former self existing basically in
brand name only
so what went wrong in this episode we'll
take a look
you are watching
[Music]
back in the 1960s a young electrical
engineer by the name of nolan bushnell
was attending the university of utah and
here he came into contact with a machine
called space war
space war was a combat video game
developed in 1962
by steve russell on a dec pdp-1 computer
nolan's university also had a pdp-1 so
it didn't take long for the game to
arrive on his campus
when nolan bushnell first played the
game he immediately realised the
potential for a coin operated
incarnation
it was by all definitions of the word
an epiphany right and i went into the
lab
and there on a screen was the game
space war but i'd never heard of it and
and i saw it then
and coincidentally i was manager of the
games department
at lagoon a local amusement park summers
and
i that was one of the ways i was putting
myself through college
and i knew that if i had that screen
in my arcades it would make money i knew
it yes
but then you do the math and you know a
million dollar computer and 25 cents a
play
and the math didn't work but
i knew the cost of computing was
constantly coming down
and i knew that the curve was going to
cross at some point
and uh and it did in 1972
noland along with his friend ted dabney
would start a company to realise this
dream
they incorporated the company under the
name atari
a term similar to checkmate in the
ancient chinese board game
go which they were both fans of
atari's first product was the world's
first commercially available video game
arcade called computer space
but unfortunately it didn't bring them
much success
next the pair hired ao acorn as the
design engineer
who created the game pong the first
atari pong machine was completed by
august of 1972
and placed in a bar in sunnyvale
california
alcorn would receive a call just a few
days later the machine had broken
this looked like a terrible start for
atari they couldn't even build a machine
that worked for more than a few days the
problem as it turned out was actually
that the coin mechanism had been flooded
with coins
because so many people wanted to play in
other words the game was actually too
successful
and from here atari was off to the races
it's big party time at at target o'clock
all the executives were in their late
20s early 30s
you're you're at what age at this time
30 okay most of the employees
were 20 to 23. wow pong was so
successful that by 1974
8 000 pong machines were installed in
restaurants amusement parks
and bars across the world however
soon after starting the successful
enterprise dabney and bushnell
started having their differences which
ultimately led to a falling out
and dabney selling a steak and moving
out
by 1975 atari now led by nolan bushnell
alone
was planning to bring video gaming to
consumers at their home
the company developed the atari video
computer system a cartridge-based
home console it used the newly available
8-bit microprocessor the mos technology
sadly atari lacked the scale to
manufacture the console for commercial
use
this led bushnell to make a decision
that would forever change the course of
atari
he sold atari to the entertainment
conglomerate warner communications in
for a whopping 28 million dollars while
all of this was going on
a series of events would set in motion
the foundations of apple computer
what was the first time that you met
steve jobs tell us about that experience
do you remember that
yeah steve jobs found atari he was
hired by al alcorn and that afternoon
he came into my office as though that
was the right thing to do
first day first day i said hi
what's up he says i think you've got a
really awesome company
awesome he uses that a lot and
and he said i think that everything is
pretty good but
i've seen your soldering connections and
they're really crappy
it's widely known that steve jobs worked
for atari before starting apple
but did you know that it was at atari
where the foundations of apple's success
was first laid
it all started when nolan bushnell came
up with the concept for the breakout
game but couldn't find
any engineers willing to design the
game's prototype
the task then went to steve jobs a
low-level technician back then
working night shifts at atari i didn't
see
the bad steve jobs but
but he caused enough problems that i
sort of put him on the engineering night
shift
which it didn't exist he was the first
member of that
during those days microchips were
extremely expensive
and nolan bushnell offered steve jobs a
100 bonus for every chip he managed to
eliminate from his concept
and it was at this moment that steve
jobs did something pretty dishonorable
here
jobs would rope in his friend steve
wozniak who was then employed at hewitt
packard
wozniak was going to help him create the
prototype in just four days
fortunately wozniak was able to complete
the prototype in four days
sacrificing his sleep jobs was paid a
five thousand dollar bonus
but wozniak who had done all the work
was only paid 375 dollars by jobs
breakout was launched in april of 1976
just a few days after jobs in wozniak
founded apple computer
wozniak had one dream though he wanted
to play a version of breakout
written completely in the programming
language basic their first computer the
apple one
couldn't do this so wozniak wanted to
create a new computer to achieve this
goal
he incorporated features such as color
graphic commands
circuitry for pedal controllers and a
speaker
this computer would be called the apple
ii and it was an instant success
and as we know the rest is history
interestingly
the apple ii actually originally sold
with two paddle controllers to play
breakout
quote a lot of these features that
really made the apple ii stand out in
its day
came from a game that game being
breakout of course
meanwhile back at atari nolan bushnell
developed differences with the warner
company and left atari in 1978.
the next year warner hired ray kazar to
take over the reigns as ceo
of atari now backed with the money of
warner media the company would create
the atari 2600 console
the 2600 featured joysticks and
interchangeable game cartridges
and thus kicked off a new era in the
video gaming industry
with warner communications at the helm
the focus of atari went from creativity
to marketing
the r d department was downsized and
replaced with mostly marketing staff
the move did pay off though the sales of
the atari 2600
started to pick up in 1979 it reached 1
million sales
and then 2 million in the subsequent
year and ultimately
leading to 10 million in annual sales in
1982.
the atari 2600 was the best-selling game
console of the time
atari's revenues comprised a huge 70
percent of owners income
before we continue today's atari news
segment is brought to you by morning
brew
later this month atari plans to build a
virtual casino inside decentraland a
crypto based virtual world
the casino will be based on ethereum and
will include atari themed games
and an atari nft it comes during an
effort to modernize the company
if you want to read more stories like
this and have an interest in science
technology and business morning brew is
a great place to get all your
information
it brings together high quality news
sources each weekday and saturday
straight to your email inbox for free
you can get up to date
with all the latest breaking news in
just five minutes and it's news
delivered in a fast and fun way
go to morningbrew.comcoldfusion or click
the link below to subscribe to
morningbrew today
it takes just 15 seconds to sign up and
it's free
by the early 1980s the video game market
was booming
and atari was the undisputed king video
games were making insane amounts of
money and there had been nothing
like it before in any industry but it
was beginning to grow too quickly to be
sustainable
the actual business of gaming was still
very young and nobody was really sure
what audiences wanted
or how to properly monetize products or
how to even reward their employees
properly
but for now all the video game markets
saw was money
and more companies jumped on board the
atari 2600 was dominant but it was also
competing against numerous home consoles
like the magnavox odyssey colecovision
and mattel in television
as the money poured into the industry it
wasn't only electronics and toy
companies that were in the market
soon companies would switch industries
just to make a quick buck
and then the market became completely
oversaturated with consoles
and yet still more kept coming
meanwhile all of these game consoles
suddenly found themselves competing
against
another brand new technology the
personal computer pcs had more utility
than game consoles
they could be business machines as well
personal computers
also featured long-term memory which
meant that games could be saved instead
of starting again from scratch
every time as computers became
affordable there was a realization that
buying a home computer would make more
sense
this would hurt the appeal of game
consoles
back then in the video game industry it
wasn't uncommon for a single programmer
to create an entire game
for their efforts programmers would be
unrecognized by atari
credits weren't allowed at atari because
atari wanted to be the only creator
associated with any work done on the
game any of the work that individuals
did was just their part of being a cog
in a machine
a programmer would typically only make
twenty to thirty thousand dollars a year
even if the game went on to sell
millions of copies
a few years earlier in 1979 a few
programmers had had
enough that year david crane larry
kaplan
bob whitehead and alan miller all left
atari to start their own company
which they called activision
atari and others sold their consoles for
cheap but expected to make the money
back on game sales
but now with activision when one of
their games was sold for an atari
console
atari wouldn't see ascend instantly
atari's business model was shattered so
of course they sued activision
but luckily for consumers atari lost in
court
now the door was open for anyone to make
games for home consoles
this would be the rise of third party
development and boy did the floodgates
open once again
everybody jumped on the bandwagon so not
only was the market saturated with
different consoles but now it was
absolutely flooded with game companies
that had no entertainment experience
whatsoever
at one point quaker oats and purina yes
the pet food company
started making video games because it
was an endless gold mine
soon more programmers would leave their
parent companies to make it on their own
atari's best programmers would leave to
join the action
as more games were made the quality
dropped
atari keen to keep making money acquired
the license to the arcade sensation of
the year
pac-man executives wanted a version of
pac-man for the atari 2600 and this
seemed like a great idea
but there was one problem atari only got
the license late in the year but still
wanted the game out by christmas this
gave the programmer almost no time to
make the game
on top of that they contacted an outside
freelancer
and they agreed to pay him a royalty fee
for every unit manufactured
not every unit sold but manufactured
atari forecast
12 million sales so they'd already
promised to make 12 million copies for
this guy
so the lucky programmer was already
guaranteed a giant paycheck before he
even had started the game
this didn't give him much incentive to
make a good game
especially because he didn't have enough
time to make a good game anyway
the result was an absolute unmitigated
catastrophe
the game was slow ugly buggy
and barely resembled the original game
that people fell in love with
atari made 12 million copies and sold 7
million
so in the end it did sell well but they
still had 5 million unsold cartridges
sitting in a warehouse
apparently they didn't learn from their
lesson the business executives
signed another deal this time with
steven spielberg to make an et game
et promised to be one of the biggest
movies of the year and it was thought
that a game based on it would sell well
again this was a good idea but once
again atari screwed up
they gave their programmer almost no
time six weeks to design
quality test manufacture and ship
an absolutely insane schedule
when the game went on sale atari thought
consumers would see the name et
and russian to buy the game but after
their experience with the pac-man
dilemma
audiences waited to see if the game was
any good
it wasn't
exactly sure what's going on
[Music]
okay i'm beginning to understand why
this is the worst game
the et game became known as one of the
worst pieces of interactive
entertainment
ever the game was the christmas gift
that everybody wanted but nobody liked
at one point things got so bad that out
of 4 million copies of the game shipped
by atari
3.5 million of them were returned these
were added to the pile of pacman games
sitting in the warehouse
so atari was making horrible games and
selling them at full price
meanwhile competitors were also making
horrible games but selling them at cheap
prices
basically the market was starting to
become obliterated
it all culminated in december of 1982
with atari's earnings statement
they told shareholders that due to all
these incredibly negative factors
the company would still grow by 10 to 15
percent and that sounds great
but the problem was before the
announcement they told shareholders that
they expected 50
growth it was a huge shock to wall
street
and this earnings report collapsed the
market
sales of both consoles and games in this
oversaturated market
crashed across the board
for many decades rumor had it tens of
millions of
unsold atari game cartridges were all
sent to a landfill in new mexico and a
bulldozer buried them and covered them
up with cement
these reports were actually proven to be
true only in 2014
when the new mexico site was dug up
atari had been the banner of the gaming
revolution and was once the fastest
growing company in american history
but now it was 500 million dollars in
debt
analysts predicted the end of the gaming
industry they told
investors and retailers alike that they
should look elsewhere
but this new little technology called
video games struggled on in pcs
and slowly continued to get stronger
atari 2 continued on after entering the
pc business
they became moderately successful in
europe with their atari st computer
released in 1985 it was praised as an
amazing tool in the electronic music
scene
this was largely thanks to the atari
st's midi capabilities
a feature only found in expensive
recording studios at the time
the atari st computer was used by music
producers like fat boy slim
tangerine dream and derude though
competing with the commodore amiga and
macintosh atari didn't end up gaining
much market share in the end
in 1993 atari wanted to stun the world
with its jaguar console
it promised to be a 64-bit gaming
console and with five different
processors
it was going to be a beast but in
reality it had average performance
was expensive was hard to code games for
which meant less games for consumers
and lastly the controller was poorly
received
all in all the failure of the jaguar
console essentially spelled the end for
atari's hardware business
before we finish up let's take a look at
a few facts about atari
even though atari couldn't maintain its
position as the market leader for video
games
their contribution was so immense and so
iconic that in 2007 the atari 2600 was
added to the national toy hall of fame
in new york sharing the honor with the
likes of the rubik's cube and lego
apart from having an apple connection
atari also has a microsoft connection
atari hired bill gates to program basic
onto one of atari's computers
bill gates kept missing deadlines and
eventually had to be fired
[Music]
it's a well-known fact that after the
decline of atari japanese game company
nintendo took its place with the
nintendo entertainment system replacing
the atari 2600
however little do people know that the
nes
almost became an atari product prior to
the crash
nintendo approached atari they wanted to
release a console under the atari brand
in the end fortunately for nintendo the
deal fell through
[Music]
so many of you may be wondering what
happened to nolan bushnell after he left
atari
well it turns out that he went on to
start chuck e cheese
he thought that a pizza restaurant would
be a simple business to start
interestingly when he had bought the
costume for his mascot
noland thought that it was a coyote but
when the costume turned out to be a rat
he decided to name the restaurant rick
ratz pizza
but the marketing team thought that a
rat would have bad connotations for a
pizza restaurant
for obvious reasons
and with that that concludes the rise
and fall of atari
thanks for watching if you did enjoy
this video be sure to head over to the
discord after this video
i'll be hanging around for the first 30
minutes after i publish this video
so i can have a chat with you all
if you're interested in taking some
atari cold fusion merge home
i've done a new limited line that you
can pick up i just love these designs
and i'm really happy with how they
turned out so if you want to support the
channel
head over to the merch links in the
description below
so my name is degogo and you've been
watching cold fusion
and i'll see you again soon for the next
episode cheers guys
have a good one cold fusion
it's me thinking
you